David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 9-152-B, the second half of the original Spool 152. It is Mr. Janis A. [sic]; he does not give his full name, he refuses to give his full name. Chicago, November the 11th, 1949, a reproduction for the U.S. Public Health Service. Boder.
David Boder: Munich, September the 24th, 1946...as a part of the German tour. I am now here at the Deutsches Museum which houses a UNNRA center and [serves also as?] the UNNRA University. The interviewee is Mr. Janis B...
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы латыш?
Janis B.: Да. Так.
David Boder: [In English]...who is here as a Latvian. He will talk to us in Russian.
David Boder: [In Russian] Мистер Джанис, Джанис, сколько вам лет?
Janis B.: 43.
David Boder: [In English] Eh, he is forty-three years old...
David Boder: [In Russian] И что вы изучаете [в университете?]?
Janis B.: Естественной науке.
David Boder: Естественной науке. Вы [неразборчиво] какую область [неразборчиво]?
Janis B.: Аг, ботанику.
David Boder: Ботанику. Вы что, раньше были в естественной науке?
Janis B.: Да. Я раньше уже в латышском университете начал, аг...аг...
David Boder: Изучать ботанику?
Janis B.: . . . изучать ботанику, но при приходе большевиков [следовался?] из занятий и сейчас здесь продолжаю.
David Boder: Это сколько лет тому назад было?
Janis B.: Это было в 1940.ом году [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Ну, аг, вам значит тогда было 38 лет.
Janis B.: Да.
David Boder: А что вы делали до университета? Вы [не из?] гимназии или гимназии [неразборчиво].
Janis B.: Я работал как [копальщик?].
David Boder: Так. И, и в городе Риге?
Janis B.: В городе Риге.
David Boder: Значит, вы, как вы мне сказали раньше, вы до того как [шли?] в университет, вы работали [неразборчиво]. Ну, хорошо, теперь начните и скажите мне подробно, потому что и важно, чтобы закончить всю историю. Понимаете? Но то, что вы мне говорите, я хочу, чтоб вы мне рассказывали [по всеми?] подробно. Я интересуюсь вашей личной историей, [не?] история [Риги?]. Понимаете? Не истории [большевиков?]. А я интересуюсь вашей личной историей. Аг, советы пришли в Ригу когда?
Janis B.: Советы пришли в Ригу в июле 1939-ого года.
David Boder: И вы были тогда там в университете?
Janis B.: Как студент.
David Boder: Вы были в университете?
Janis B.: Да.
David Boder: Ну, расскажите, что случилось с вами, что случилось [в университете?].
Janis B.: Дело было так, что при приходе большевиков, а, часть студентов должна была [следить пред вахте?] аг...
David Boder: Занятий.
Janis B.: . . . занятий, потому что все, которые считались националистами начали [все размыть?] исследования от [большевиков?]
David Boder: Так. И что с вами [случилось?]?
Janis B.: Так как отец мой имел имущество [с домом?] в Риге, то, значит, я считался капиталист, ино-капиталистом, и потому уже на меня смотрели как на человека, который [неразборчиво] противника [после фашистского?] режи...режима.
David Boder: Ну...Тогда что с вами случилось?
Janis B.: Дом наш был национализирован и...и [проход сам?] [заикающийся], в то же время как я был у [неразборчиво], я тоже в то же время работал, аг, в частном, аг...
David Boder: В частном [деле?], аг, в частной, аг, конторе.
Janis B.: В конторе. Там мы [many неразборчиво] [взял?], опять [свои?] [неразборчиво] и так как я [это сделал начальник?] организация, что [здесь?] считался подозрительный и так после этой [ясности?] я был тоже [убежден?] быть [неразборчиво] предполагаемыйся выслать в Сибирь.
David Boder: Ну, что вы тогда сделали?
Janis B.: Я, так как [уже?] настроение было...ну, начались, аг, [среди?] знакомых уже, некоторая часть была, аг, некоторые части знакомых была [sic] уже...
David Boder: Арестована.
Janis B.: . . . арестована, то уже не могла в университете заниматься, потому что уже [тихий].
David Boder: [Ну, да?] [неразборчиво]. Потому что, что?
Janis B.: Потому что уже
David Boder: [прерывающий] [неразборчиво] [полицейский?] если выпадает [все?] [тихий и неразборчиво]
David Boder: Да.
Janis B.: Опять это [неразборчиво] [пытался бы грузить туда из?] [турщина?].
David Boder: Ну, дальше. [неразборчиво]. Потом [сейчас лучше?]
Janis B.: [неразборчиво]
David Boder: [Стоп?]. Вот, что вы считаете важным, что у вас лично. Что потом лично с вами случилось?
Janis B.: Так. Дом отца был национализирован [неразборчиво] жители оставить [неразборчиво] в свою [неразборчиво] квартиру и вся семья переместится в другой, меньшей квартире.
David Boder: [А скажите?]. Дом выл национализирован. Кто его взял? И кто туда [переехал?]?
Janis B.: Аг, никто не приехал, но он был [открыто?] и мы не могли [квартирную?]...ог...
David Boder: [неразборчиво] вы взяли?
Janis B.: Одну часть [неразборчиво] был отставлен.
David Boder: Так, и квартирные платы вы тоже не могли взять.
Janis B.: Нет.
David Boder: А там другие люди остались жить?
Janis B.: Другие остались [уже?].
David Boder: [неразборчиво] жили?
Janis B.: [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так. И вы [заставили сам?] и они платили за квартиру, но как [неразборчиво] взял деньги?
Janis B.: Ну, за квартиру сам, аг...
David Boder: [прерывающий] [неразборчиво].
Janis B.: [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так...А где же вы тогда сами, что с вами делал? Вы человек женатый?
Janis B.: Нет, я не женатый.
David Boder: Так. Ну, так. Что тогда с вами случилось?
Janis B.: Я продолжал...
David Boder: Предполагались что делать? Работать?
Janis B.: Аг, я продолжал работать.
David Boder: Печатное...
Janis B.: [прерывающий]...печатное дело, потому что я работал там бухгалтером и директор был [и?] поставлен из коммунистов, но он [неразборчиво] только 22, аг, 22 года, аг...
David Boder: Ему было только 22...
Janis B.: [прерывающий] Только 22 года. Он совсем ничего не знал о деле бухалтерии, ни о печатном дело [исправление] деле, а так что он должен был на некоторое время все [уставиться?] в, аг, старых [неразборчиво]. Но постепенно [тех?], которых аг, мог, мог он [всем?]-нибудь другими-то [месяцы?] все были отпущены.
David Boder: А было много латышей коммунистов? [Никто говорили?], что они коммунисты?
Janis B.: Это трудно сказать, потому что во всех собраниях когда если кто-нибудь о них забыл [отклонять?], тогда председатель собрании [спрятал?] всегда, есть кто-нибудь против [вещего?], потому что [будет?] понятность, а никто не смел сказать, что он против этого. Так, что [все эти?] люди принимаются [целесообразно по части может быть там [78, почти?] 90% были бы против этого.
David Boder: Ну, и что вы, там работали до сих пор пока немцы пришли?
Janis B.: Да, до тех пор. Аг, потому что аг, большие аг, массовое высланное на Сибирь началось только 14.го июля, но...
David Boder: Какого года?
Janis B.: 1940.го года.
David Boder: А немцы пришли когда?
Janis B.: 1940.го года 1.го июля.
David Boder: Так, что они имели время [неразборчиво] только две недели?
Janis B.: Две недели. И 22.го июня началась война так, что аг, эта вы...высылка была прервана.
David Boder: Война. Аг, они начали [выслать?] 14.го июля.
Janis B.: Гмм.
David Boder: 22.го началась война.
Janis B.: Война.
David Boder: Значит, [всего?] они высылали [неразборчиво] 8 дней.
Janis B.: Да. [неразборчиво]
David Boder: [Сколько вы считаете?] ли они [выслали?] [неразборчиво].
Janis B.: Предположительно...аг, предположительно 60,000.
David Boder: Так...[Выше?] 60,000 людей были [неразборчиво].
Janis B.: [неразборчиво]
David Boder: Знаете вы, что с ними там случилось?
Janis B.: Не знаю, потому что почти никто не вернулся обратно, потому что потом после этого пришли немцы и фронт был теперь...
David Boder: [неразборчиво]
Janis B.: [неразборчиво]
David Boder: Ну, хорошо. Где же вы самы были? Каким [был?] [образом?] вас не выслать?
Janis B.: Все [неразборчиво] время...там [такой?] [неразборчиво] аг, выяснилось [скажем?] учреждения был так называемый кадровый [отдел?] и там были, там были [неразборчиво] списки из, аг...из, аг, из тех [неразборчиво], которые считали подозрительными. Но, [неразборчиво] не было, [только за годы?] самых аг...
David Boder: Подозрительных.
Janis B.: . . . подозрительных. Так что [мой?] [неразборчиво] [был таможник?] произвел шляпы после этой [неразборчиво] [месяца два?] в кухне. Ну, так как началась война, то благодаря этому они не успели все, всех [добиться?].
David Boder: Ну, хорошо. Вот значит [немцам?]. Что случилось со всеми этими, которые были вашими начальниками [неразборчиво]?
Janis B.: [Большая?]. Аг, все начальники, которые были подавлены в большевистское время все вместе большевиками, аг, ушли.
David Boder: Они были тоже эстонцы?...[неразборчиво] они были тоже эс [stops]. Были, аг, извиняюсь, они были тоже латыши?
Janis B.: Нет. Аг, аг, ах, директор не был латыш, директор был русский, и главный бухгалтер тоже [неразборчиво] русским...которые уехали вместе с коммунистами от Рос...[исправление] из России.
David Boder: А на каком языке книги были?
Janis B.: Книги [неразборчиво] еще на латышском языке.
David Boder: Ну, да. Значит, пришли немцы и что случилось с вашим [печательством?]? Это что было, государственное [печательство?]
Janis B.: Государственное
David Boder: [прерывающий] Что там печатали?
Janis B.: Там печатали [все?] деньги, облигации, и тоже книги.
David Boder: Ну, да.
Janis B.: [неразборчиво] [студенты?] наше печатное не, не [подтверждало?] от того.
David Boder: [От того не подтверждалось?]?
Janis B.: От прихода немцев. [Отстал?] до вот [остановками]
David Boder: Ну, да.
Janis B.: Сейчас не была [целая?], не была разрушена.
David Boder: Дальше.
Janis B.: Так, что работа могла продолжаться. Аг, деньги больше не, не велик, не печатали больше, потому что тогда опять была [введена?] новая валюта, немецкая, все, аг, немецкие деньги высылали из Германии, но [печатное?] продолжала [неразборчиво] печатать книги и разные необходимые бумаги.
David Boder: Ну, а скажите мне вот, что...это...и при советов печатали деньги там?
Janis B.: При советов [тоже?] печатали деньги.
David Boder: Латыш? [неразборчиво].
Janis B.: Нет, не латышские, [значит все было?] везде введены рубли.
David Boder: Ну. Значит немцы пришли. Что тогда случилось с вами и вашей семей? Отдали вам дом обратно?
Janis B.: Нет, сразу не отдало. Только сказали, что [после этого?] будем получить обратно.
David Boder: Вы получили тогда? [тишина].
Janis B.: Там нужно было взять разные доказательства, что этот дом нам раньше принадлежал, но так как, аг но официальную бумагу не получили, что этот дом опять нам принадлежит.
David Boder: А, квартирные деньги, а квартирные деньги стали получать?
Janis B.: Квартирные деньги стали получать, но они должны были [штатный фонд?] и только одну часть могли [за месяц?].
David Boder: А остальное [неразборчиво]. Ну, дальше. Что вы делали тогда? Продолжали вы быть бухгалтером?
Janis B.: Я продолжал быть бухгалтером.
David Boder: И...дальше как немцы тогда с вами обращались? [Забыл о?] [неразборчиво], так?
Janis B.: Да.
David Boder: Ну, как они с вами обращались, аг, с населением?
Janis B.: Ну, когда сперва немцы пришли, все очень радовались, потому что думали, что будет много лучше. Но, [после?] оказалось, что не у немцев не особенно хорошо, потому что как мы знаем немцы [ликвидировали никаких других?] народов [неразборчиво] [себя?].
David Boder: Ну, а...
Janis B.: Но, но...
David Boder: Начали они кого-нибудь арестовывать?
Janis B.: Они арестовывали в некоторых частях тех, которые избежали, аг, аг...о которых думали, что те работали вместе с большевиками.
David Boder: [начали они?] много людей арестовать?
Janis B.: Из нашего учреждения нет...
David Boder: [прерывающий] Нет, я думаю [по еврей?]
Janis B.: Вовсе [неразборчиво]
David Boder: А вот именно? Латышей?
Janis B.: Латышей тоже [неразборчиво] русских, евреев.
David Boder: Так. На, и что они с евреями делали?
Janis B.: С евреями они...они [посылали?] жить в отдельный квартал...
David Boder: [прерывающий] на гетто [неразборчиво], да?
Janis B.: Да, [в гетто?].
David Boder: Ну, дальше. А потом что они...а потом что они с ними делали?
Janis B.: Потом было [разговорен?], что одна часть гетто отправляется, отправляется, но что с ними делается могли только предполагать, что что-нибудь [все хорошее уже нет?]
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 152 in the middle of an interview with Mr. Janis from Latvia. We will continue on the Spool 15— ah, 153.
Herman Barnett: Spool 153, Spool 153. Spool 153, this is Herman Barnett.
David Boder: Spool 153. Munich, September the 24th, 1946, at the Deutsches Museum which houses the UNNRA University for displaced persons. The interviewee is Mr. Janis B....forty-three years old. Continuing from Spool 152.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну, значит, что тогда случилось?...Вы [неразборчиво] оставались работать там до каких пор? Что случилось с вашими родителями?
Janis B.: Во, во, во время прихода Немцов в Ригу моя матья аг, от, была убита от разрыва гранат. От гранаты.
David Boder: Что? С большим боем Ригу взяли?
Janis B.: Да. В предместьях в Риге произошли [неразборчиво] бои. Там...Там после прихода немцев [еще несколько дней?] на улицах [боя из струкции руко-...рукопаши?] русским, русские там так, потому что немцы [то их у Польши?] сразу [похоронили?], но русские еще несколько дней [сдали хуже?].
David Boder: Так.... Ну, значит, мать ваша убила [неразборчиво] гранат. Аг, отец?
Janis B.: Отец остался жив, потому что аг, мы [жили?] до, аг, за, за рекой, которая протекает аг через Ругу, за Двиной. И я во время прихода аг, немцев не был в своей квартире, потому что [описался?] что большевики [неразборчиво] [уходе?] войск [за плятина сухой?], потому я спрятался у знакомых в другой квартире.
David Boder: Так. А разве [были?] вас там не могли нашли? Они что, брали под [списком?] или искали [людей там?]?
Janis B.: Нет. Они брали под [списком?], потому что [у жителей списки?] [неразборчиво] дому [приех...?] аг, подвешивали на автомашинах и под списком забрали [всех?].
David Boder: Так. Ну, хорошо. Потом как же вы, когда же вы ушли из Латвии?
Janis B.: Я ушел из Латвии в 1944.го года, 4.го октября.
David Boder: Это когда немцы ушли из Латвии?
Janis B.: Да. Тогда уже фронт был около 30 километров [только?] от Риги и было [введено?] распоряжение, что все мужчины должны э...
David Boder: Эвакуировать.
Janis B.: . . . эвакуировать, да. И в дом пришли немецкие жандармы и сказали, что если еще [должен встретить?] [неразборчиво] мужчины будут [неразборчиво].
David Boder: И тогда, вы, значит, что?
Janis B.: И сказали, что...что можно идти [в гавань?] и там сесть на пароход и, и уехать в Германию.
David Boder: Так. И, и тогда вас куда увезли?
Janis B.: Меня привезли в Данциг.
David Boder: А отца вашего?
Janis B.: Отец мой был [sic] 73 года, а, 73 года. [Остан?] и, и...
David Boder: И он оставил в Ригу.
Janis B.: . . . и [болелся?], так что отстав, остался [дом?]
David Boder: Немцы позволили ему остаться или он просто так остался?
Janis B.: Он просто так остался, потому что сказано было, что [неразборчиво/тихий].
David Boder: Ну, так привезли в Данзиг. Что вы тогда сделали?
Janis B.: Меня привезли в Данзиг и сперва сказали, что там оставить две недели. Но потом нас [находились?] в поезд и увезли в [неразборчиво], [тюрьме?] так называемый [Штутов?] лагерь.
David Boder: Да.
Janis B.: И оттуда две недели нас, нас не выпускали [нигде?].
David Boder: А потом работали вы у немцев?
Janis B.: Потом нас опять посадили в поезд и...и [еще?] меня и около 30 человек повезли в Гамбург.
David Boder: Так.
Janis B.: И там мы должны были работать аг, в фабрике.
David Boder: А здесь когда вас, аг, где вас освободили?
Janis B.: Меня? Меня освободили англичане 1.го мая...
David Boder: Мая. Где? В Гамбурге?
Janis B.: Да. [В предместье?] Гамбурга
David Boder: [прерывающий] Вы работали там на фабрике?
Janis B.: Да, на фабрике.
David Boder: Ну, а что немец...вы работали вместе с немецкими рабочими?
Janis B.: Нет. Нам давали работу самую тяжелую.
David Boder: Тяжелая. И кто работал? Только латыши?
Janis B.: Нет. Там работали еще [вывезенные?] украинцы, [вывезенные?] французы и [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так.
Janis B.: И я работал там как [неразборчиво] [транспортные?] работы [неразборчиво] пароход поезда.
David Boder: Так. Ну а как же вы из английской армии попали в Мюних?
Janis B.: Я из, аг, после аг, [приход?] англичан, я остался жить аг, там в лагере, потому что во, во время пока я работал в фабрике, я жил в лагере. Нам немецкие [неразборчиво] [не выдавали?], но нам питание давали в лагере. И после приход[а] англичан, я [лично?] узнал, что немцами здесь УННРА открывает университет. Там я хотел продолжать свои [предвоенные?] работы. [неразборчиво].
David Boder: А скажите, у вас родственники в Америке есть?
Janis B.: Нет. У меня [опять?] [неразборчиво].
David Boder: И что вы собираетесь делать [когда окончен?]?...Или если УННРА уедет, что вы собираетесь делать?
Janis B.: Пока я [неразборчиво] все время [всем?] [неразборчиво] [может быть?] должен попасть обратно на [родину?].
David Boder: Что? Если вы можете попасть [неразборчиво]?
Janis B.: [прерывающий] [Да, да?]. [Известно?] там опять большевики. Так как я уже в своей жизни два раза вышел из большевиков, 1939.ого года и 1940.го года и знаю, что...у них...я...я [неразборчиво] [будет?] в своем родном городе, будет опять [что-нибудь в другом?] [неразборчиво] пока не могу вот [неразборчиво] [торопиться?].
David Boder: Так. А вы что [тихий и неразборчиво] отец?
Janis B.: Это есть у нас надежда...[неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так...Я [был?] очень благодарен. [Я?] хотел с вами говорить [неразборчиво] говорить с многими студентами и поэтому мы заключили этот интервью...
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Mr. Janis, a Latvian, forty-three years old, a student at UNNRA University at Deutsches Museum in Munich. September the 24th, 1946, Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.